und jetzt ist es passiert freunde aus
der thüringen krise ist endgültig eine
cdu krise geworden annegret kramp
karrenbauer schmeißt hin
also vielleicht erst zum jahresende aber
so oder so ist das natürlich ein hammer
ein echter hammer meine damen und herren
denn egal ob sparen laschet märz oder
söder deutschlands nächster kanzler wird
in jedem fall ein mann ein mann meine
damen und herren das ist erstmal ein
schock
logisch und ein offenes rennen ein total
offenes rennen denn die sind ja alle
vier wahnsinnig beliebt nach einer rtl
forsa-umfrage sind für friedrich merz 27
prozent für armin laschet 18 markus
söder 11 jens spahn 8% und keiner davon
sagen 36 prozent klarer sieg klarer sich
davon
wer noch ein prima wahlplakat keiner
davon cdu
jeden tag spekulationen jeden tag jetzt
neue schlagzeilen märz tritt an söder
macht sparen wartet ab wer ist dieser
laschet eine nach der anderen und klar
posterboy und liebling der konservativen
cdu bleibt natürlich friedrich merz ist
ja logisch wer sonst auch diese woche
haben sie ihn schwer gefeiert zb beim
treffen des wirtschaftsrates der cdu in
magdeburg
also in sachsen anhalts einem bundesland
in dem es offensichtlich eine
rechtschreibreform gab es heißt jetzt
sachsen-anhalt meine damen und herren
bitte
[Applaus]
das niveau gehalten
das hinterland des ostens der spitze war
diese woche regelrecht auf tournee also
im grunde wie so ein popstar seine rede
gestern beim forum mittelstand in berlin
haben sie auf zwei sendern live
übertragen live weil nur friedrich merz
den finger legt in die alternde cdu
wunde das erstarken der politischen
ränder ist auch nicht nur aber auch ein
ergebnis von orientierungslosigkeit und
empfundener führungslosigkeit bravo
bravo die leute wählen nämlich nicht afd
weil in ihrem dorf kein bus mehr fährt
sondern weil die cdu kein führer hat
keine führung hat friedrich merz hat
gerade den aufsichtsrat von blackrock
verlassen das heißt wenn es mit der
kanzlerschaft wieder nicht klappt steht
dieser mann vor dem nichts vor dem
nichts
ja aber wer weiß vielleicht wird es ja
auch jens spahn seine kampagne ist ja
längst fertig das ist wissen sie ein
ein typ wie obama nur völlig anders und
der jens kriegt gute noten in letzter
zeit seit er eben nicht mehr ständig
über den islam redet und als
gesundheitsminister richtig was weg
schafft und dann ist da natürlich müssen
sie armin laschet der knuffige hobbit
aus aachen und der wird immer noch gerne
unterschätzt von den leuten weil er so
wahnsinnig niedlich ist da war davon sie
nicht täuschen lassen der armin ist vor
allem optimal vernetzt in seiner partei
der cdu und wissen nicht viele
er spricht mehrere sprachen manager
allofs zusammen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fallera lala und die zuschauer alles
lastet lachen
er hat wohl sagen zumindest eingeweihter
experten ganz gute chancen in diesem
rennen aber er hat auch ein manko
er gilt nämlich als merkel anhänger ja
ja und damit macht man sich in teilen
der partei keine freunde mehr
und ich wette vor allem junge zuschauer
die quasi unter merkel aufgewachsen sind
die fragen sich seit dieser woche
was ist denn überhaupt die männliche
form von kanzlerin
da muss man die kinder schon darauf
vorbereiten noch klingt es absurd ein
mann als bundeskanzler
geht das überhaupt und was kommt da auf
uns zu das problem des männlichen homo
sapiens ist sein sexualhormon
testosteron die folge aggressivität und
imponiergehabe
nun reden sondern auch nicht so einen
stuss stadt ist rogan politik also
erstmal nachdenken und dann aussitzen
sieht politik unter testosteron einfluss
so aus mindestens einmal im monat haben
eine unerklärliche stimmungsschwankungen
wenn ihre fußballmannschaft verliert der
männliche kanzler sucht ständig
natürliche feinde
er erkennt sie am mikrofon und
presseausweis diese bilder beweisen
richtig bei sich ist ein kanzler nur
wenn etwas zu trinken und was zu
krabbeln das fazit was da auf
deutschland zukommt ist gar nicht so
schlimm
nur anders männliche kanzler nicht
optimal
[Applaus]
ja
so
wenn man mal überlegen was da passiert
ist ja annegret kramp karrenbauer war
schon ein echter pannen magnet
beeindruckende pannenserie aber es ist
menschlich hat die frau hat ihr amt als
ministerpräsidentin für berlin
aufgegeben und jetzt schickt man sie
eiskalt wieder nach hause ins saarland
ja ohne rückporto plus du kannst du
unerträgliche heuchelei ihrer
parteifreunde respekt annegret danke
annegret aber mach bitte auf keinen fall
müsste dezember weiter ekelhaft und
selbst cdu die ihr noch bei springen
wollen tun sich irgendwie schwer also
wir sind feststellen dass wir die
staatskrise in thüringen ermöglichen
von seiten der cdu war auch manche
anderen parteien verantwortlich sind und
nicht von der sache völlig richtig in
der sache völlig richtig bis auf das mit
herrn möhringen den gibt's gar nicht
aber sonst ja völlig richtig angela
merkel hat aus afrika einen thüringen
machtwort gesprochen ohne not und damit
final demonstriert wie wenig sie ak noch
zutraut da war die autorität durch den
schornstein spätestens jetzt ist klar
diese kanzlerin hat doch die cdu
parteiführung nie wirklich abgegeben ja
die war nie wirklich weg nein weil dies
dies heimlich immer chefin geblieben
deshalb ist die kanzlerin zusammen mit
ak auch selber gescheitert diese woche
und ihre reaktion auf thüringen war eine
idiotische steilvorlage für die afd
man muss doch jede formulierung
vermeiden klingt wie ein schloss das
volk so lange wählen bis es passt wie
kann man denn sagen dass dass dieser
vorgang unverzeihlich ist und deshalb
auch das ergebnis wieder rückgängig
gemacht werden muss hat die da in afrika
zu lange in der sonne gestanden oder was
ja man darf das ja furchtbar finden was
in erfurt passiert ist aber es ist
natürlich trotzdem demokratie auch wenn
es wehtut so läuft das eben wenn die
feinde des parlamentarismus in
parlamenten sitzen
die verteilte cdu das ist viel wichtiger
als personalfragen diese verteilte cdu
muss jetzt mal erklären wo sie
eigentlich hin will
links oder rechts da gibt es einerseits
die ost verbände die mit der afd
zumindest flirten aber eben auch so
flippige typen wie diesen herrn günther
aus kiel ministerpräsident daniel
günther hat sich ausgesprochen
für tabulos reden mit der linkspartei
tabulos reden hinter linken vielen dank
jetzt bin nicht geil meine damen und
herren tabulose rahmenlos aus deiner
nachbarschaft wollen dich durch
koalieren ja es ist ein total rotes tuch
diese ideen mit ramelow was zu machen
vor allem für die berühmte werte union
mit ihrem omnipräsenten vorsitzenden
alexander mit ja kennen sie die werte
union die sind tatsächlich nur ein
verein also gar keine cdu organisation
sind nur ein verein haben nach eigenen
angaben gerade mal 4000 mitglieder
das ist unter ein prozent der cdu
mitglieder trotzdem wird in einer tour
über die berichtet ja man hat den
eindruck sobald sich irgendwo mehr als
zwei leute von der wert union zum kaffee
treffen gibt's sofort eine live-schalte
und wir schalten wir live zu einem
kaffeetrinken der bayerischen werte
union meine damen und herren
geleitet von antonia vonhausen frau von
kosten was ich da gerade bei ihnen im
wohnzimmer sehe ist das jetzt schon die
komplette bayerische werte union
[Gelächter]
witzbold nein natürlich sind wir nicht
die komplette bayerische wette union
sind wir die komplette bayerische um
mal prima es ist wirklich ein rätsel
frau von außen ihr bundesvorsitzender
der alexander mit der wird gerade rund
um die uhr interviewt von weise nicht
bild bis bravo der dritte auf eine
kreuzung aus bundeskanzler und großwesir
mindestens aber hat der typ kein mandat
für nichts
der mann ist im letzten herbst bei der
wahl zum beisitzer im vorstand des cdu
kreisverbands rhein-neckar gescheitert
weil er gemobbt wird weil die anderen in
der cdu es nicht ertragen die
kompromisslos ehrlich der alex ist ja
also für mich ist er der elias im
barrique der deutschen politik extrem
männlich aber auf eine zerbrechliche art
der welt wir haben es so sagt jetzt auch
noch an den rechten rand gedrängt zu
werden
hörens dem alex doch einmal zu und
insofern ist habe ich auch kein problem
mit moslems an sich die sich hier
anpassen und es gibt es auch es gibt
menschen werde er ist verheiratet sein
sohn ist mit meinem zur kommunion
gegangen der coop fußball er trinkt er
arbeitet ja und jetzt noch einmal zum
mitschreiben die werte union hat nichts
gegen moslems die katholisch sind und
biertrinken noch kommen wir gar nichts
dagegen die können es gerne bleiben wenn
sie arbeiten und bier trinken ja bei
dalli dalli hat schon mal gesagt
betrinken war zwei mal müssen wir eines
abziehen
wenn ich mir das genau ankuppeln gibt es
ja schon programmatische
überschneidungen zwischen ihnen und der
afd
das schmarrn aber gott dann schauen wir
uns halt mal die kernforderungen unserer
welt ohne begrenzung der netto
zuwanderung auf null wir prüfen eine
wiedereinführung der wehrpflicht dann
zum schutz der deutschen sprache
sämtliche mittel der gender
mainstreaming forschung streichen
außerdem laufzeitverlängerung von
atomkraftwerken logisch und wir fordern
das ende von angela merkels
kanzlerschaft wo sind die jetzt bitte
überschneidungen mit der afb wo und dem
übrigen herr welke nur weil man zufällig
exakt dasselbe will wie die fdp ist man
doch noch lange nicht die afd
die bayerische werte union schreibt in
ihrem klima manifest es gebe keinen
zusammenhang zwischen co2 ausstoß und
erderwärmung diese annahme sei und ich
zitiere mit wissenschaft eigentlich
dürften über euch gar nicht berichten
die träumens weiterer welt für
deutschlands medien sind wir purer sex
ja hier breaking news werte union stellt
zwei neue bücher vor
alexander mit wie ich mal fast beinahe
um ein haar beisitzer im cdu
kreisvorstand rhein-neckar geworden wäre
und sachbuch die angebliche schwerkraft
eine dreckige lüge der müll wissenschaft
ja die tat- bist du eigentlich antonia
wird auswahl damen und herren fielmann
[Applaus]
alter der kleb hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gold ich
habe es noch drauf
also ich würde den kanal direkt
abonnieren und auf gefällt mir drücken
wenn ich das nicht so getan hätte das
war wirklich stark
[Musik]